what I heard director Justin Lin the
director of the conjuring and insidious
was taking over the franchise
I knew the franchise was gonna change a
little bit but honestly it doesn't look
like any of the other Fast & Furious
movies Witek played by Vin Diesel man
this guy scary [ __ ] Jew this student
is so [ __ ] badass man Vin Diesel is
the [ __ ] in this movie it's called
Riddick how is Riddick in this film
Riddick he kicks [ __ ] ass I can
honestly say this is the best one out of
the trilogy granted this is the first
one I've seen out of the trilogy but it
is probably the best one he's stuff when
I heard like I thought you did such a
good job that it made me want to watch
pitch black and Chronicles of Narnia and
then top it off with Chronicles of
Riddick
what's up that too he just does a really
good job in this movie like he does get
a shot his acting a little bit he's not
just some action hero you know like
though the first 20 minutes of this
movie is a little bit like I am Legend
on another planet and yeah he like
befriends a dog and they put a lot of
focus on this dog and you're like eyes
are somewhat focused on this dog as time
progresses you begin to love the little
CG [ __ ] but he's interacting
with this like CG dog and he's very
believable in it and then you get to see
like different sides of Vin Diesel's
character in this one you know you need
to see his human side it's when he's
interacting with a puppy the interested
humans he's a [ __ ] jerk you know his
first name is Richard totally works
because he's a dick what I love about
this movie is it's like a a real sci-fi
film nowadays we when we get like
science fiction movies a lot of movies
are technically science fiction but in
this particular case this feels like a
throwback vibe you know kind of got a 95
in there
how it's divided into like three
sections the first section is more of
like a survivor type of tale and it
features a strong cameo by Karl Urban
yep he's in it those four lines he had
powerful and then the second part is
like the hunt for RIT RIT experice eken
Park which leads me to my next topic the
ensemble of this film great ensemble
there's this guy who's like the leader
of half of the groups of people that are
trying to hunt down Riddick he he starts
off scary but then eventually becomes
really funny and he's a really good
actor and I kind of liked him a lot
even though he is he does do something
like creepy stuff but easy people you
like him at just the right times and
this other guy he's a lot like Robert
Forester case you guys know where that
is he the only movie I've seen him is
Jackie Brown but apparently is a famous
actor and he reminds me of this guy did
he got this like hot lesbian man I wish
I could like get a sex change operation
then have sex with her she punches my
favorite supporting character in this
film several times imagine what else she
could do with that fist everything about
this works the directing of it really is
solid because to pull up a film that has
like three different vibes as the third
part is a lot like pitch black in a way
from what I remember from the trailer
and you need a good director who could
pull off three completely different
types of acts in a movie surprisingly
the truth'll happy to believe it like
this forms of a part of an action
there's really not a whole lot of action
but when the action is there it's cool
you know honestly just when Vin Diesel's
there it's like action is happening
already just the way he talks
sounds like an action scene yes there's
a few flaws here and there like there's
some super convenient plot points they
used a [ __ ] word specifically [ __ ]
they use that word a lot in places that
don't really seem to match with a
dialogue some of the dialogue sounds
like a writer wrote the dialogue and it
occasionally drags would she have sex
with a drag queen but I'll see I watch a
movie like this for the entertainment
the grand scope of things not just the
tiny things that don't work let me get
straight to the point here oh no I gotta
save ready gutting right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
review for Riddick why don't you go
ahead scroll that comment box below and
tell me if you're a lesbian would you do
something with me and want to go ahead
and follow me on Twitter you click the
link right here that's for you lesbians
and if you want to see a more in-depth
review of Riddick go ahead and check out
myself called reasons to see no that's a
man right there not a lesbian
his name is Jerry and last but not least
if you want to get updated every time
one of my reviews is out go ahead and
click on this but about my penises
subscribe haha let me just fix that real
fast
haha but about my penis
that's right it's ridiculous